My children share a bathroom.
They are 6 and 8,
which means it is a mix of glittery makeup and little boy pee.
It's really gross. Today I walked in here,
cannot even believe the smell of urine.
I swear, we just clean this,
and for some reason, it still smells.
And look in this mirror, like,
can you tell that it is streaked and slimy?
It is so gross.
It literally looks like I am a ghost because of how gross is.
I don't know what's on there.
So we're gonna use my handy dandy
Shenley steamer to get rid of all of the odors.
This thing is so nice. I'm going to attempt to use the, like,
sponge head. I'll show you in a sec.
I'm gonna attempt to use the sponge head on the sink and the counter.
But the grime and gunk on here.
I might need one of these,
so we'll see. But this baby is powerful.
It works so well. And it
was able to deep clean their entire bathroom floor to ceiling,
with just my shiny steam up.
It is so, so good.